[Música]
puede ser tal vez uno de los negocios
del año y sus repercusiones se sentirán
en los próximos días o tal vez meses el
que es considerado como el hombre más
acaudalado del mundo tomará control de
twitter una de las redes sociales más
importantes y utilizadas a nivel mundial
después de haber pagado nada más y nada
menos que 44 mil millones de dólares y
lo en moscú buscará darle un nuevo rumbo
a esta red social según sus palabras e
intentará que sea un poco más moderada
en su contenido también espera
desarrollar nuevas herramientas
tecnológicas pero la gran pregunta está
relacionada con las garantías en cuanto
a la libertad de expresión finalmente
esta red social es un negocio y tendrá
que dar beneficios y eso también implica
tener estrategias de negocio pero en su
momento y los moscú fue crítico de
twitter señalaba esta red social por la
forma en que era utilizada esto lleva
entonces a una gran expectativa en torno
a los cambios que puede llegar a ver
veamos
qué es lo primero que hace después de
lograr un acuerdo para comprar twitter
twittear sobre ello al menos eso fue lo
que hizo él en más que tras pactar el
lunes la adquisición del gigante de las
redes sociales por unos 44 mil millones
de dólares dirigiendo a la empresa hacia
la esfera privada calificando a twitter
como la plaza del pueblo digital más que
dijo que quiere mejorar la plataforma
añadiendo nuevas características el tema
principal en la mente del hombre más
rico del mundo es la libertad de
expresión más que lleva tiempo
criticando la moderación de contenidos
de twitter que considera ahoga la libre
expresión de los tuiteros actualmente la
red social prohíbe a los usuarios cuyos
tuits se consideran racistas o
despectivos pero más que quiere una
pausa en lugar de una prohibición total
avivando los temores de que cierto ex
presidente pueda volver a la plataforma
thompson acaba de decir hace diez
minutos que no quiere volver a twitter
no significa que quiere volver a twitter
sabe que hay 80 millones de seguidores
esperándole ximos que está realmente a
favor de la libertad de expresión no
puede simplemente no dejar volver a
trump eso es seguro al fasher donald
trump que ahora tiene su propia red
social ha dicho que es poco probable que
vuelva a twitter pero los planes demás
han tocado la fibra sensible de los
críticos incluso en la casa blanca
llevamos mucho tiempo hablando y el
presidente lleva mucho tiempo haciéndolo
sobre su preocupación por el poder de
las plataformas de medios sociales
incluyendo twitter y otros para difundir
la información errónea la desinformación
la necesidad de que estas plataformas
sean responsables el empresario también
ha insinuado que se centrará en los
ingresos por suscripción para reducir el
número de anuncios en el sitio una
propuesta arriesgada para una empresa
que ya está en dificultades y que no ha
obtenido beneficios al menos durante los
últimos dos años como lo decía el
reportaje twitter es considerada como
una gran plaza pública mundial donde hay
todo tipo de debates de críticas se
habla de temas vitales hay también
espacio para las denuncias para los
anuncios para la publicidad en fin son
múltiples los usos que tiene y también
el potencial que tiene es completamente
enorme hoy en el debate de france 24
analizamos lo que significa esa nueva
alianza en donde hay muchos intereses
pero seguirá los pasos que vaya dando
poco a poco bajo esta nueva
administración para analizar este tema
hemos invitado a hitler y roberts beatle
ellas editora para code story es experta
en derechos digitales y también está con
nosotros juan luís conde asesor legal
para empresas tecnológicas y fundador de
novus concilium ustedes también nuestros
televidentes pueden participar en este
debate con todos sus comentarios con sus
preguntas también importantes es para
nosotros conocerlas lo pueden hacer a
través de nuestras redes sociales no se
encuentran en facebook en instagram en
twitter también estamos allí nos
encuentran como france24 bajo ese i
arroba santi logo que es mi cuenta
personal le recuerdo que nuestra
etiqueta es numeral el debate efe 24
esperamos los comentarios y las
preguntas en torno a este tema que tiene
con mucha expectativa al mundo entero y
por eso lo traemos aquí al debate de
france 24 en nuestro espacio directo
américa edición nocturna pues comienzo
entonces con hitler y en la ciudad de
filadelfia en eeuu para conocer detalles
de su opinión como punto de partida y le
pregunto bueno primero hillary
bienvenida al programa y comienzo
preguntándole en términos económicos y
en el mundo de la tecnología que
significa que hiló en moscú se haya
hecho con esta red social de importancia
global
bueno
agradezco para la oportunidad de hablar
con
ustedes
desde mi perspectiva lo cual es
realmente
con cada decisión grande así con las
plataformas tecnológicas más importantes
para la libertad de expresión la
pregunta siempre es bueno
como cuáles serán los efectos en todo el
mundo de un cambio tan significativo
[Música]
la mayoría de las conversaciones que yo
he visto en internet en medios sociales
twitter sobre todo am son demasiado
enfocados en los efectos dentro de eeuu
los efectos para
las accionistas de la compañía los
efectos para agentes súper poderosa como
donald trump por ejemplo
pero hace falta mirar
el mundo entero y preguntar bueno cuáles
serán los efectos para gente por ejemplo
que están intentando usar en plataforma
y como usted dijo a denunciar cosas
importantes para criticar a
a centros de poder a gobiernos para
hacer periodismo por ejemplo y lo que
hemos visto en los últimos 12 10 años es
que un lugar como twitter la gente que
tienen más poder pueden usar sus voces
para promover sus agendas para atacar a
voces disidentes a voces críticas
y de ahí
en esta idea que más tiene
abrir el plataforma de
de promover la libertad de expresión de
una forma absoluta revelando funciona
para todos no puede funcionar de forma
igual para todos los usuarios claro
juan luís le doy también la bienvenida
del programa y como punto de partida
quiero conocer sus impresiones en
términos de lo que representa esta venta
o esta compra desde el punto de vista de
donde se mire en términos económicos y
en términos de tecnología lo que
significa esto para el desarrollo de las
plataformas y de las redes sociales a
futuro
claro que sí muchas gracias por el
espacio creo que el impacto va a ser muy
importante y muy considerable en
términos prácticos me parece que
por lo menos con esta transacción y los
modos que va a tener él por lo menos
legalmente el poder para
implementar los cambios al producto de
twitter inc que en este caso es la
plataforma que él considere adecuados y
sería desde mi perspectiva iluso pensar
que va a encontrar mucha resistencia
habida cuenta que es muy probable que
adquiera todas las acciones que
representan el capital social y con ello
tenga el poder para designar consejeros
y por lo tanto también para designar a
los oficiales de la compañía el impacto
en la plataforma va a ser inmediato
porque considero que ello nos trae una
idea muy al menos que para él es muy
clara de que es lo que quiere hacer y va
a encontrar pocas fricciones para ellos
el impacto hacia otras plataformas pues
será más interesante para ver el mercado
cómo se mueve es decir las plataformas
que compiten con twitter en el tema de
anuncios pues verán y estarán analizando
muy de cerca para ver que ellos que cómo
se adapta no va a estar interesante
hitler y pasó a preguntarle ahora por un
tema que ya usted venía tocando en su
respuesta anterior es el tema de la
libertad de expresión y yo lo decía
también en la introducción esto no deja
de ser un negocio no deja de ser una
transacción cómo lograr hacer ese
balance entre la garantía para los
usuarios de sus derechos de expresión
derechos humanos también garantizar los
derechos humanos en este tipo de
plataformas cuando se tiene un negocio
detrás cuando se necesita dar ganancias
cuando se necesita dar buenos resultados
sobre todo en una coyuntura como en la
que estamos en este momento en el mundo
en donde la mayoría de las economías a
nivel mundial están tratando de
recuperarse después de el
parón que tuvimos por decirlo así por la
pandemia de kobe 19
bueno creo que es importante mirar para
atrás porque en los primeros años de
twitter
la idea era ser el plataforma para la
libertad de expresión fue muy muy
importante en el discurso de
actores y otros líderes de la compañía
lo que encontraron
que no era tan fácil
alcanzar ese equilibrio
de esther habla entre el negocio y los
derechos de los usuarios y te digo que
en
no sé
2015-2016
llegamos un punto donde había mucha
gente que se fueron del plataforma
porque no no podrían más con el acoso en
línea con el discurso del odio con
varios otros asuntos que fueron super
serios entonces es el equilibrio no es
es complicadísimo alcanzar y no sé
en realidad no sabemos qué va a ser más
ahora tiene ha hecho sus discursos y sus
tweets sobre lo que quieren sus ideales
pero realmente es
para mí tenemos que vamos a ver
si la expectativa como lo decía yo en la
introducción del programa es a nivel
global sobre todo lo que pueda pasar en
términos administrativos de estrategia
del negocio y también el manejo que le
puedan dar a la plataforma juan luís
siguiendo en línea y
siguiendo este hilo de la conversación
en el término de los derechos y las
garantías para los usuarios en el herri
lo mencionaba muchos usuarios dejaron
esta plataforma precisamente porque eran
víctimas de bullying acoso y hay
colectivos a nivel social que se han
quejado por ejemplo los colectivos de
mujeres sienten que no tienen la
igualdad de espacios que el resto de la
sociedad también el colectivo lgtb está
y ha estado ahí presente haciendo
algunas algunas quejas sobre el manejo
que se le da a la plataforma para los
espacios que ellos han reclamado es
verdaderamente neutral twitter es
verdaderamente un espacio en donde
cabemos todos en esta como decía yo
plaza pública mundial o esta es una
plaza pública mundial para algunos
definitivamente me parece que solo para
algunos y es importante decir porque uno
de los conceptos yo tuiteaba hoy en la
mañana creo que el error más grande que
podemos hacer es ceder ante la idea de
que twitter es una plaza pública porque
no es ni una plaza ni es pública
las barreras de acceso que tienen muchas
personas para poder acceder a este tipo
de servicios son reales y son tajantes y
cuando hablamos de barreras de acceso no
solamente hablamos en la brecha digital
porque no toda la gente tiene acceso a
un celular o acceso a una computadora
también hablamos de acceso a internet de
alta velocidad pero además de eso
también podemos hablar de literaria
digital no no mucha gente estamos
preparados para usar estas redes
sociales de la mejor manera posible y
desde luego que existen
reclamos muy válidos de grupos que se
han visto afectados por temas de
violencia digital como los que usted
comenta al final del día la violencia y
tal es absolutamente real y los impactos
que tiene en la vida real
un chistecito entre comillas que alguien
pueda hacer en twitter es que es muy
real a mí me parece muy difícil hablar
de libertad de expresión
porque coincido con con el eur y estamos
en temas totalmente
especulativos no sabemos a qué se está
refiriendo y los moscos con libertad de
expresión no sabemos qué entiende él por
libertad de expresión o en que se está
basando para decir que quiere libertad
de expresión hoy tuiteó diciendo que él
dice que libertad de expresión es lo que
diga el derecho pero qué derecho estamos
hablando de los criterios
jurisprudenciales que han tenido la
suprema corte americana o tomar en
cuenta lo que dice la organización de
las naciones unidas ese es un tema muy
complejo y que desde luego twitter no es
el mejor lugar para estar discutiendo de
él
me parece interesante recalcar que para
tener conversaciones complejas sobre
temas reales e importantes en una
sociedad democrática como es la libertad
de expresión y los daños muy claros que
puede tener a ciertos grupos de ciertas
personas
necesitamos medios muy complejos para
debates muy complicados que sin duda
alguna no se pueden hacer en medios que
te permiten expresarte en menos de 280
caracteres
claramente también hay que anotar que
por ejemplo el twitter es una plataforma
en donde se etiqueta algunas de las
publicaciones vemos las etiquetas que
reciben las publicaciones hechas por
medios chinos o por medios rusos o por
periodistas de estos países sobre todo
ahora en el marco de esta guerra entre
rusia y ucrania eso en cierta forma
también es una discriminación del
contenido puede usted tener la opinión
que tenga sobre rusia y sobre la forma
en que china maneja su política al
interior del país pero sin duda alguna
se está haciendo una
la diferenciación en cuanto al contenido
es difícil entender entonces estos
espacios en internet en general como
espacios donde hay verdadera libertad de
expresión
definitivamente internet si es un
espacio de libertad de expresión si
podemos expresarnos todos o es como
cualquier otro medio de comunicación que
ya está cortado
es un bueno internet
hay gente que dicen que es un lugar
otros que dicen que son
forma de existir
pero
lo que sabemos ahora con
12 años de experiencia con con
medios sociales super grandes y globales
es qué
bueno de acuerdo con juan luís
es imposible
y manejar un plataforma así
la escala global sin
sin tener ciertas reglas y
constantemente pensar en estos
no sé en español como decir 2
como
compensación es porque los los derechos
de todos son no es y casi nunca es
posible es satisfacer a lo que se
necesita a los derechos de todas las
personas entonces
es un acceso en un equilibrio que que
las redes sociales todavía no han
encontrado pero lo que preocupa a mí es
que y lo más que es 1
un multimillonario que tiene experiencia
con varias empresas gigantes pero que no
tienen mucho ni nada que ver con estos
asuntos por ejemplo él dice bueno vamos
a vamos a ambos
seguir las reglas las leyes y donde
existimos bueno pero la ley en eeuu la
ley en colombia la ley maryland acá
donde en ese asunto es complicadísimo
sin considerará a otras políticas son
reglas en el plataforma quieren mantener
para sus propios intereses
claro bueno dejó de lado un poco este
tema de la libertad de expresión es un
tema que veremos más adelante en el
desarrollo de las semanas siguientes
cuando esta plataforma ya quede bajo la
nueva administración y quiero hablar de
algunas de los puntos de sus
lineamientos básicos que ha dado mosca
sobre los cambios que quiere hacer para
twitter cómo se va a traducir esto en el
día a día vemos por ejemplo que él ha
dicho que quiere
menor moderación la reincorporación de
personas que han sido vetadas son
algunos de los temas que quedan así como
que uno no sabe que pueda llegar a
suceder
ha criticado mucho la política de
moderación de los contenidos que hay en
twitter y que quiere generar mayor
cantidad de ingresos por supuesto
monetizar que es el fin económico de
todo este tipo de plataformas moderar
menor moneda moderación para dar
libertad de expresión esto como lo
podemos entender esto como puede cambiar
reglas lo de la incorporación de
personajes como por ejemplo donald trump
si se une o no como lo puede entender
usted de juan luís
creo que es muy difícil y creo que
estamos en el área de la especulación
porque literalmente lo que estamos
viendo es una persona que puede imponer
su visión para bien o para mal sobre
cómo va a funcionar un producto en lo
práctico creo que se va a traducir en
que vamos a ver cambios en los famosos
términos y condiciones o en las
políticas de uso aceptable del sitio que
reglas se van a incluir en esas
políticas es difícil decirlo porque
volvemos a lo mismo no estamos
entendiendo realmente a qué se refiere
con estos conceptos y creo que para para
que nosotros podamos decir efectivamente
cómo se va a ver o cómo se va a traducir
el cambio que necesitamos entender a qué
se refiere con estos conceptos
cuál es su marco teórico qué son las
reglas que en qué reglas se va a basar o
cómo lo va a ser a mí qué me gustaría
ver si me permiten hacer una carta con
los mejores deseos a mí me gustaría ver
la incorporación de un consejo
interdisciplinario con gente experta en
en tecnología en ética para poder guiar
la mejor implementación de las diversas
leyes y de los diversos límites que
tenemos a la libertad de expresión para
saber qué cuentas tienen que estar
prohibidas y que cuentas no es decir
como cómo podemos tomar una decisión es
sin ser por qué por qué no la gente que
está dentro de twitter o los oficiales
de twitter que están ejecutando esos
términos y condiciones difícilmente son
jueces difícilmente tienen la
preparación la experiencia la
capacitación de jueces que se dedican a
analizarse una conducta es ilegal o no
para atribuirle consecuencias jurídicas
cómo vamos a poder hacer eso o cómo se
van a implementar esos en la práctica es
algo que es muy interesante y que creo
que es importante como usuarios pues al
menos levantar la voz y la iv y ponerlo
en contexto juan luís continuó con usted
para hacer la ronda a la inversa y le
preguntó por la monetización muchas
personas no entienden cómo esta
plataforma gana dinero si es una empresa
rentable o no de acuerdo a lo que he
leído no es una empresa que genere mucho
dinero y les costó mucho llegar a un
punto de equilibrio cómo puede mejorar
entonces la monetización aquí ya me meto
en el tema netamente empresarial de lo
que puede llegar a suceder
administrativamente
yo creo que la mosca ha manejado que
quiere navegar a otros modelos de
negocio el modelo de negocio actualmente
que tienen este tipo de
plataformas de medios sociales es que tú
puedes acceder a utilizar la plataforma
de manera gratuita no pagas nada por
ello sin embargo vas dejando un
un pedacito vas dejando un rastro que
son tus datos personales y la plataforma
lo que hace es que los compila hace una
digamos un perfil de quién eres con base
en tus en tus consumos con base en el
tiempo que pasas viendo la pantalla qué
cosas le das like con quién interactúas
que compartes etcétera
y luego vende esos esos esos perfiles a
otras empresas que se anuncian en todo
realmente lo que venden este tipo de
plataformas son anuncios super dirigidos
a personas que en teoría van a ser mucho
más susceptibles a lo que el anuncio te
está pidiendo puede ser comprar un nuevo
champú para la ducha o puede ser votar
por un partido político y todo lo que
quepa ahí adentro y lo que creo que
puede suceder es que vamos a cambiar
este modelo de negocios quizás lo más
que empiece a migrar sea otros modelos
como puede ser el pagar por el contenido
al que puedes acceder a lo mejor va
haber contenido pagado o contenido no
pagado a lo mejor podremos tener ciertas
suscripciones para acceder a otros tipos
de cuentas de otros tipos de personas a
lo mejor nosotros como cuentas vamos a
poder cobrar por los tweets no lo sé
alejarnos del sistema de publicidad
implica quizá el pago por cierto
contenido pero es difícil saber qué es
lo que lo que lo nos tenga en mente en
específico no el euro está siendo de
alguna es una noticia sumamente
importante a nivel apenas se dio a
conocer el anuncio la acción de twitter
subió cerca de un 28 por ciento
esto me recuerda un poco a la década de
finales de los 80 y de principios de los
90 cuando los grandes medios de
comunicación de eeuu de europa hay
muchos de américa latina' eran vendidos
a grandes conglomerados o
personas adineradas para conformar
precisamente grandes conglomerados de
medios de comunicación como los que
vemos hoy en día estamos ahora ante el
inicio de una ola de compras por parte
de millonarios o de grandes empresas
para conformar grandes conglomerados
informativos este puede ser el inicio de
un gran conglomerado en manos de moscú
como lo ve usted
guau la verdad no sé
[Risas]
[Música]
parece o se siente como una un cambio
súper importante para el sector
hasta ahora
[Música]
los fundadores sitios de las empresas
más grandes
e influencia les dentro de los
plataformas de internet y medios
sociales esos fundadores y líderes todos
eran gente
trabajan en la tecnología y que
pensaban que imaginaban
varios modos de conectar a las personas
y abrir espacios para hablar y debatir
en cierto momento
llegó la idea podemos ganar plata con él
los los avisos con
[Música]
si con la publicidad las publicidades y
de ahí cambiaron muchísimo los
plataformas
ahora estamos llegando quizás a otro
momento en que gente que vemos que no
tienen
viene de otro
[Música]
de otra expansión y con no tiene tanta
experiencia dentro de la tecnología
dicen bueno tengo la plata porque no
compro esta plataforma a ver qué que
podemos hacer y qué más podemos ganar
hablando de plata
y juan luís cuál es su presión que
podamos ver que a la vuelta de una
década esté en las grandes plataformas a
las que estamos acostumbrados de todo
tipo para ordenar comida para pagar por
un servicio de transporte para conocer
personas para publicar información como
twitter queden en manos o concentradas
en unas pocas manos a nivel
internacional como sucedió con los
medios de comunicación en el pasado
creo que es un tema que es importante
abordar y que no debemos de quitar el
dedo del renglón en hacer esas preguntas
porque efectivamente cuando tienes
muchos capitales que controlan o sea
mucho capital concentrado en pocas manos
que puede llegar a controlar
la información que está dada y la
información que consumimos
es algo que debe de levantar foco o debe
levantar banderas y debe de prender
focos rojos para poder ver qué tanto no
estoy diciendo que quizás se tenga que
regular inmediatamente hay que ser muy
cautelosos con la regulación pero es
importante hacer esas esas preguntas a
mí me parece muy importante
también
recalcar la necesidad que existe de
tener transparencia en los algoritmos de
cómo funciona esta presentación de
información que nos están dando porque
quizá cuando nosotros consumimos medios
impresos cómo está el caso de diez besos
que compra el 'washington post' pues
sabemos muy bien cuál es la línea
editorial sabemos muy bien quién tomó la
decisión
nos están presentando esta información y
quizá podemos tener podemos tomar una
decisión informada el problema que
tenemos con estas redes es que los
algoritmos son muy oscuros realmente no
sabemos porque lo que me sale en mí en
mi línea en twitter o en mi pantalla en
twitter porque me sale a mí y es
simplemente
justamente usted se adelanta a mí
siguiente pregunta que va a hacer que
era que se traduce eso que han anunciado
y que se ha comenzado a debatir en
internet sobre la transparencia acerca
del algoritmo que utiliza esta
plataforma eso en términos simples para
el usuario del día a día que pone
twitter simplemente para leer noticias y
para publicar y re publicar algún tipo
de información qué significa
bueno creo que es
adelante el que te quite la palabra
adelante y la palabra en otro tema
perfecto bueno para mí es muy importante
porque tenemos que entender o cuando uno
habla de algoritmos parece que estamos
hablando de algo muy mítico o muy
místico y que es difícil de comprender
sin duda alguna son los algoritmos son
recetas procesos procedimientos que son
muy complejos y que están codificados en
el código fuente de plataformas o de
programas de cómputo es algo
evidentemente es muy complejo pero
básicamente lo que hace este tipo de
algoritmos es presentarnos y
hacer que la computadora o hacer que el
programa de cómputo tome decisiones de
manera automatizada sin intervención
humana en un ambiente de incertidumbre
qué significa esto que existe una
decisión automatizada que no ve un ser
humano de qué información se presentan a
ti y eso es importante porque no sabemos
nosotros como usuarios no sabemos cuáles
fueron los criterios para presentarnos
la información que nos están presentando
parece que fuera algo muy orgánico que
fuera algo muy natural y parece que toda
la gente está viendo la misma
información que yo estoy viendo pero no
es así y eso crea un gran riesgo porque
se ha hablado incluso de las burbujas
cada quien está recibiendo su
información que puede ser información
correcta que puede ser desinformación
que puede ser info demia y cada persona
está recibiendo información totalmente
distinta en todos cuando queremos ir a
una plaza pública de verdad a platicar y
a debatir sobre temas trascendentales
cada quien trae conceptos
diferentes distintos pero ni siquiera
sabemos cómo aproximarnos esos conceptos
se me hace muy peligroso que no exista
la transparencia para que nosotros como
usuarios podamos decidir qué información
consumimos y cómo la consumimos claro y
ese es el debate central que ha traído a
colación este este tipo de transacción a
nivel internacional que llama la
atención a todo nivel por las
consecuencias que pueda traer esto ya
llegó al final del programa los últimos
minutos para hacer las conclusiones y
cerrar este tema sé que hay muchas
aristas y estamos también en cierta
forma en un terreno de la especulación
porque las verdaderas consecuencias de
esta transacción a nivel internacional
las vamos a empezar a ver en los
próximos días y semanas pero era
importante traer este tema al debate por
por lo que significaría a futuro y
precisamente hacia allá va mi pregunta
para la conclusión hitler y yo sé y
siempre lo digo acá no tenemos la bola
de cristal para saber qué es lo que va a
pasar pero desde su perspectiva desde su
campo de análisis y de conocimiento que
puede suceder en la industria de la
tecnología que puede suceder en la
industria de las redes esto es un
parteaguas es un punto de quiebre o es
simplemente una transacción más que va a
traer una renovación a una compañía
bueno
creo que eso es algo
es algo súper importante y qué
podría
imagino que va a tener
[Música]
perfectos consecuencias
grandes y quizás graves
[Música]
usuarios para
comunidades que dependen en twitter
[Música]
y también como hablábamos antes podría
ser un momento en que estas empresas
también empiezan a ser
aún más como una comodidad y menos como
un espacio para para
debate
nunca eran perfectos nunca funcionaron
de misma forma para cada usuario pero
hemos visto momentos en los últimos 10
años donde esas plataformas pero en
fundamentales para
gente que no tienen mucho poder ni mucha
plata para organizar debatir hablar
expresarse y
según algo está en las ideas que hablaba
juan luís
capaz que estamos llegando a un lugar
donde
estas plataformas son más para gente y
compañías que tienen poder que para la
gente
normal así que para la gente del común y
corriente que es lo que uno pensaría que
es la mayoría de los usuarios de twitter
por ejemplo personas del común que
acceden allí para publicar información o
acceder a información cuál louis su
conclusión para el cierre que viene para
este tipo de empresas para esta
industria para la sociedad
bueno creo que es algo muy interesante y
para hacer el ejercicio yo creo que en
lo muy práctico vamos a ver cambios
organizacionales y de producto muy
claros muy definidos y probablemente muy
rápido que van a estar impulsados por la
agenda que ha delineado
el señor y los mosca
que tanto la el mercado va a responder a
esos cambios va a ser interesante verlo
porque no existe como hoy por hoy no
existe una red social parecida a twitter
pero eso no quiere decir que no compita
con otras redes sociales o con otra
forma de con de consumir contenidos allí
está muy bien también posicionado tick
tock ahí está muy bien posicionado digo
quién sabe qué tanto instagram no
conozco los números pero vamos a ver si
el mercado y nosotros los consumidores
en específico quieren seguir consumiendo
este producto o si mejor se van a ir a
otra plataforma que eso también es un
riesgo que puede existir muy claro y
grave y lo que comentaba el oro y creo
que lo que a mí sí me gustaría ver y que
creo que no va no tristemente
va a ser difícil ver es como este tipo
de herramientas efectivamente se pueden
usar al servicio de todas del general de
la población y no solamente al servicio
de un cierto grupo que quiere manipular
ciertas percepciones o pro o avanzar
ciertas agendas pues a juan luís ya el
eri les agradezco mucho por haber estado
con nosotros en el programa por haber
analizado este tema para la audiencia de
france 24 les agradezco mucho haber
compartido sus puntos de opinión en
torno a este tema ustedes pueden seguir
dejando todos sus comentarios y sus
preguntas a través de las redes sociales
tema importante muchos de nuestros
usuarios nos siguen a través de estas
plataformas y nosotros tenemos contacto
con ellos a través de twitter
precisamente siempre lo anunciamos al
inicio del programa así que veremos en
los próximos días y semanas cuáles van a
ser esos cambios que va a recibir
twitter para los usuarios y para seguir
informando los a través de esta
plataforma por el momento no es más los
dejo con más información en directo
américa edición nocturna
[Música]